Whoa.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today's topic is the Hungarian language
or my job and he has,
as it's called in Hungarian.
Hungarian is not just another European
language.
There's nothing else quite like it for
starters,
it's not an Indo European language.
So when you look at a map and see that
Europe's Hungarian speaking areas are
surrounded by Indo European languages,
you have to ask yourself,
how did Hungarian get there?
Most Hungarian speakers live in the
carpathian basin,
bordered by the Carpathian mountains to
the north,
east and south.
That includes not only around 10 million
speakers in Hungary,
but also in areas of the basin in
neighboring countries,
including Romania,
Serbia,
Croatia,
Slovenia,
Austria,
Slovakia,
and Ukraine.
The largest Hungarian speaking minority
is in northwestern and central Romania
were around 1.2
million people speak at or around 6% of
the country's population.
All of these Hungarian areas in the car
pay the invasives.
We're part of the Kingdom of Hungary
until 1920 when many areas were seated
to other countries.
But how did they get there in the first
place?
Hungarian is a member of the eugric
branch of the urologic language family,
which originated in the vicinity of the
Ural Mountains,
which separate Europe from western
Siberia.
The urologic languages include two main
groupings,
semiotic,
which was the first group to branch off
from your Alec and Pheno eugric around
2000 bce or maybe earlier Finnell eugric
split into protal Eugric,
the ancestor of the eugric branch,
and Prodo Finnick,
the ancestor of the Finnick languages,
including finish and Astonian.
Prodo eugric remained a unified language
for more than a millennium until
Hungarian diverged from it around 800
bce.
There's some debate about whether the
Hungarian ethnic group,
the man jars,
originated to the west or to the east of
the euro mountains.
But at some point around 2000 years ago,
they became nomadic in response to
changes in climate and landscape,
and began gradually migrating towards
the West,
eventually reaching the Carpathian basin
in the ninth century,
both while settled near the Ural
Mountains and while migrating west,
the madge,
ours had extensive contact with Turkic
peoples.
For instance,
the my jars formed part of a tribal
alliance with Turkic tribes called on.
No good meaning 10 tribes,
which was based in the northern Black
Sea area.
This,
by the way,
is the most likely origin of the term
Hungarian and it's equivalent Udon Gotti
and Latin uhmm [inaudible] in Greek and
own Goodie in Podo Slavic after the
owner Guler alliance disintegrated,
they became part of the cozaar connate,
a Turkic Empire covering much of the
Caucasus region and the Black Sea area
for a time.
They collected taxes from Slavic people
on behalf of the Kossar's until they
became politically independent from the
Kossar's in the year eight 30 this
interaction with Turkic tribes and
political entities led to significant
Turkic influence on the Hungarian
language.
It's hard to give an exact count of the
number of Turkic loan words in
Hungarian,
but this lexicon contains around 500
loan words from old Turkic.
Also,
the old Hungarian script developed from
the [inaudible] script,
the Turkic runic script that was used by
the Kossar's in the ninth century.
The majora's.
We're carrying out frequent raids in
Europe and in the year 896 they crossed
the Carpathian mountains under the
leadership of outer pod and began
settling in the Carpathian basin by the
year 1000,
uh,
Christian kingdom was established under
King Stephen.
The first under him Hungarian began to
be written in the Latin Alphabet,
but for some time the old Hungarian
script was used as well for vernacular
writing.
It was used by the [inaudible] until at
least the 17th century and since the
early 20th century,
it has undergone a revival to some
extent with limited use for symbolic and
cultural reasons.
Stephen the first also med Latin,
the sole official language of Hungary.
And it remains so until the 19th
century,
the old Hungarian period,
the old Hungarian period conventionally
begins with the settlement of the car
pay the invasive.
This is around the time of the earliest
fragments of written Hungarian,
which date back to the 10th century and
a written than the old Hungarian script.
Isolated words written in the Latin
alphabet can be found dating back to the
mid 11th century.
And the oldest extensive texts is from
1192 the late 12th century.
Hungarian has changed relatively little
since the old Hungarian period,
but due to contact with other languages
and the assimilation of other tribes,
it has absorbed words from a variety of
languages,
including German and the erotic and
Slavic languages as well as Latin and
the Turkic languages we've already
discussed.
Middle Hungarian,
the Middle Hungarian period began with
the printing of the first books in
Hungarian.
During much of this period,
the Ottoman occupation of central and
southern Hungary took place and the
Habsburg empire ruled the northern and
northwestern areas,
which likely brought some additional
Turkic,
specifically Turkish and dramatic
influences to the language modern
Hungarian.
In the 18th and 19th centuries,
Hungarian underwent a language reform in
order to standardize it,
to make it more suitable for literature
and to make it more suitable for the
sciences.
They revived old vocabulary,
used existing routes and fx station to
create new words and introduced some
dialectal words on a national level in
order to expand the vocabulary.
In 1836 it became the official language
alongside Latin,
and in 1844 it became the sole official
language of Hungary.
From 1867 to 1918 the kingdom of Hungary
was part of the Union of Austria,
Hungary.
In 1920 after Austria,
Hungary is involvement in the first
world war.
The treaty of Triano redrew the borders
of Hungary and assigned many of its
areas to neighboring countries based on
the ethnic composition of their
populations.
This resulted in the current situation
in which millions of Hungarian speakers
live outside of Hungary in neighboring
countries,
despite the fact that Hungarian has
ancient connections to other urologic
languages today,
it's similarities to them are not
immediately obvious,
and despite the fact that Hungarian
vocabulary has been widely influenced by
other languages,
the borrowed words are mostly older
words that are further obscured through
compounding and affixation.
For example,
the word Goomba,
meaning mushroom.
This was borrowed from old slavonic
Goomba.
In modern Bulgarian,
it's Guba and in Super Mario brothers,
it's Goomba.
But this word can also form a compound
word with this word here,
Sienna meaning species.
Goma Fayetta means fungus to make it
plural.
We add a k Goma ferric.
Then there might be a case ending gum
buffet cat.
Now what's in the accusative case?
You may be thinking,
Hey,
that beginning part is still
recognizable to speakers of Bulgarian.
Yeah,
maybe.
But in other Slavic languages,
that route is not so commonly used
anymore or has changed more than it has
in Bulgarian.
Like in Slovak.
It's who the main point I'm getting at
is that a lot of the loan words in
Hungarian or not immediately
recognizable,
but anyway,
that brings us to the most important
question.
What's Hungarian?
Like?
Hungarian is an a gluten native
language,
meaning that words are made up of a
linear sequence of morphemes that each
contribute a piece of meaning to the
word.
So let's start with this word.
Vital meaning city.
For the plural,
we add oh vital,
she'll meaning cities and for words
ending in a vowel,
you just add.
For the first person,
singular possessive.
We add boom of auto show,
meaning my city.
Now let's make it a location of
[inaudible] means in my city.
This here,
by the way,
it was the definite article,
which we'll look at a little later.
So you can see how we start with the
root word and add suffixes to it to add
meaning,
but the suffixes are not always exactly
the same.
For example,
Jeb meaning pocket for this word,
the plural would be Jeff Beck.
My pocket [inaudible] my pockets in the
plural [inaudible] in my pocket.
[inaudible] them in my pockets or
champagne,
Ben.
So what's up with all the ease instead
of the oes and the a is we saw in the
first word,
well,
Hungarian features something called
vowel harmony.
This means that the vowels which appear
and suffixes depend on the vowel in the
final syllable of the word.
So the suffix is in the first example.
Vitals are in harmony with the vowel.
Oh,
and the suffix is in the second example,
Jeb are in harmony with the vowel e.
The exact value used also depends on the
type of suffix.
We can also see vowel harmony and a
gluten nation in Hungarians verb
conjugations.
The base form of the verb meaning to
write is ead for regular verbs.
These verb endings here are added to
verbs with one of the following vowels
in the final syllable.
The base form of the verb,
meaning to drive or to lead is visit.
These verb endings here are added to
verbs with one of the following vowels
in the final syllable,
either shorts he or long Ie.
The base form of the verb meaning to sit
is these endings right here are added to
verbs with any of these vowels in the
last syllable,
but there's more.
These conjugations you see here are
indefinite conjugations.
Transitive verbs in Hungarian have
different conjugations depending on
whether the object is definite or
indefinite.
Let's take the verb to write in.
Edo means I write or just eeoc because
Hungarian is pro drop,
meaning the subject pronouns can be
dropped.
Edo Call Amit,
I write something beat Oak Ridge.
Can you vet I write the book here we
have a direct object and edge is an
indefinite article Util mcha and Yvette.
I write the book is a definite article
and you dome is the definite
conjugation.
Hungarian verbs also have past tense
forms,
both definite and indefinite ones with
almost no exceptions.
There is no separate form for future
tense,
but the future can be expressed using
the infinitive of a verb plus the
present tense of the verb folk knee.
So I will write a book is evening,
so we'll catch you Yvette and I will
write,
the book is [inaudible].
There are also numerous prefixes which
can be added to verbs,
some of which add a new shade of meaning
to the verb and others which completely
changed the meaning of the verb before
we saw the verb,
which means to sit as in you are
currently in a seated position.
If you want to express the meaning of
sit as in sit down,
you add the prefix net load and it can
also mean to serve like in this phrase,
meaning to serve a prison sentence.
[inaudible] to say sit up.
In other words,
to stop slouching.
You say fed who bevel means sit in
sometimes used for getting into a car
and Lou means to sit still or to sit
away from the prefix.
[inaudible] means away.
This word also means blow over or
subside.
And before we saw the verb visit,
meaning drive or lead,
and it also means to conduct electricity
live as that means drive down like from
a hill or from the capitol to the
countryside.
But it also means deduce bev as it means
to drive into.
And it also means introduce,
in other words to put into practice fan
of as that means mislead or deceive.
And there are numerous more the way that
these prefixes,
ultra or the meanings of words is not
always consistent.
So you can't always just put two and two
together,
but sometimes that works.
There are also a couple of types of
suffixes that can be attached to the
verb to change its meaning,
but at depending on vowel harmony or
that that show causation.
For example,
visit means drive or lead visit.
That means make someone drive and after
that you can add verb endings to
conjugate it,
like visit the drink.
We make someone drive and that's the
indefinite form.
By the way,
visit that Duke is the definite form
visit that you Daniella as,
oh this means we make Daniel drive the
car.
Leather is the instrumental case suffix,
which is used here to show who is being
caused to do something.
It's basic forms are evolve and vel
depending on vowel harmony.
But when attached to announce ending in
a consonant,
The v assimilates to the final consonant
resulting in germination,
uh,
doubled.
Consonant Oz is the definite article
before we saw the form awe,
but when the noun begins with a vowel,
then the form Oz is used.
The term at the end of our tote is the
accusative case ending,
which is used to indicate the direct
object cases.
One of the most notorious aspects of the
Hungarian language is it system of cases
which are attached to nouns.
There are 18 cases though.
Some people will say there are more.
Look at these tables for the noun
meaning car.
This looks pretty intimidating.
However,
most of these case endings function in a
similar way to prepositions in English,
except that they are after the word.
In other words,
they're like post positions.
Take the date of case form.
Oh,
don't fuck.
This means to the car.
The instrumental case,
oh,
dovall would mean by car the terminated
case.
Oh de League would mean something like
as far as the car.
For example,
if you were going to walk until you
reached the car,
the ines IV case,
oh bum would mean in the car,
the ablative case,
outdoor coil would mean away from the
car and so on.
So thinking of them as post positions
rather than case endings might make it a
little less intimidating.
And it may look like there are separate
forms for plural nouns,
but the really aren't.
The plural forms simply have the plural
suffix [inaudible] and then the case
endings are added after that.
The only tweak to that is the double
consonant in the instrumental case that
we saw before,
as well as in another case called the
translative case.
Unlike in many other languages,
cases only affect nouns,
not adjectives or articles.
In addition to cases,
there are also possessive suffixes and
these can be used together with various
case endings.
Oh Dome my car.
And to express this fully,
we need to use the definite article
[inaudible] I am in my car as oh towed
your car and she shit cause I'm walking
away from your car.
Or maybe it would be as [inaudible].
I'm walking away from your car with the
emphasis on your car.
Hungarian word order is not set in
stone.
When something appears before the verb,
it is emphasized,
so by moving the Noun to the beginning,
we are placing emphasis on it.
The verb prefix or pre verb l meaning
away also moves out of the way when
something else is placed in front of the
verb to emphasize it,
it's like the main verb is handing the
emphasis over to whatever comes before
it,
but if there's a pre verb in the way,
the main verb can't pass the emphasis,
but if the pre verb gets out of the way,
then there's nothing blocking the
emphasis from being handed over.
Since these pre verbs can be split from
the main verb,
they can be referred to as co verbs.
Let's add an adverb to this sentence as
shit [inaudible].
This means I'm walking slowly away from
your car with no particular emphasis now
loves sean shade.
That'll cause a toto.
This means I'm walking slowly away from
your car with the emphasis on slowly
when there's an explicit subject placing
it before the verb places emphasis on
it.
If there's no pre bourbon,
the way Michael [inaudible],
Michael is walking slowly away from your
car.
This sentence has no particular
emphasis,
but let's get the pre verb out of the
way.
My good shape that allison has,
oh,
toto Michael is walking slowly away from
your car here.
The emphasis is on Michael because it
comes right before the verb.
My coolest [inaudible] Michael is
walking slowly away from your car.
Again,
the emphasis here is on La Shaunn slowly
because it comes right before the verb.
This position right before the verb is
the most emphatic if the verb comes at
the beginning before an explicit subject
than the verbus emphasized,
but for this sentence,
the meaning wouldn't really make sense.
A couple of notes on Hungarian phonology
and orthography in terms of phonology
and orthography Hungarians,
not exactly the simplest language out
there.
There are 14 vowels.
This includes seven pairs of short and
long equivalent with the acute accents
indicating long vowels.
One of the immediately noticeable
features is the double acute accent to
show the long equivalents of the vowels
with uhmm louts.
There are also 30 consonants for a total
of 44 letters in the Hungarian alphabet,
but some of the consonants consist of
two or three orthographic letters.
These consonants with Y,
our palatalized consonants,
and there are these others.
See s equals chuck,
D,
Z,
s equals j,
e,
s,
z equals C and Z,
s equals g.
In addition to palatalized consonants,
another common phonological and
orthographic feature is germination
lengthened consonants that are
represented by double consonants in
writing.
If you see a sentence that contains
double consonants,
consonants followed by Y and multiple
acute accents,
Uhmm,
louts or a double a cute accent,
then you're almost certainly looking at
Hungarian.
Let's look at one final sentence in
Hungarian and break it down.
Now,
everybodyokay Hash,
mathematic ab,
that damage cabbies album.
The sentence means I'm not hungry
because I already ate lunch at a cafe
word for word.
It's no,
I am hungry because already I have
lunch,
a cafe in first we see the negation word
Nem.
This word doesn't change and you just
put it before the part of the sentence
that you want to make negative.
There are other forms of negotiation as
well,
but this is the basic way in indicative
sentences.
Next we see video which means I am this
ending.
Oh is a typical present tense ending
meaning I with its vowel harmonizing
with this a vowel awe.
But this verb is a rather special one in
irregular verb.
Removing oak would give you the third
person singular present tense form.
But for this verb,
[inaudible] is the second person
singular and the third person singular
is Vaughn.
It also has a different past tense stem
voight and it's also the only Hungarian
verb with its own inflected.
Future tense form.
Other verbs express the future using two
verbs like we saw before.
A Hash is the word for hungry.
The singular form of this word is always
the same and has never inflected for
gender or case and be that,
um,
is the first person singular past tense
of the verb,
meaning to have lunch and the identity
which has the base form and Ba da them
is the first person singular past tense
inflection and vowel harmony determines
that it's dumb.
Not Dumb.
This is the indefinite conjugation.
But for the first person singular past
tense,
the definite and indefinite forms are
actually the same edge is the indefinite
article.
Got Album is the word for cafe with the
NSF case ending bond.
In other words,
it's like a post position meaning him,
and it's worth noting that this ending
is bond,
not Ben,
because it's in harmony with the,
Oh,
at the end of Kava is old.
As you can probably see,
Hungarian is quite different from any
Indo European language and it's
different from any other language.
In Europe.
It's a gluten native grammar and it's
now in cases which functions somewhat
like post positions are somewhat similar
to other pheno eugric languages,
but there are also differences and it
contains much less Finnell eugric
vocabulary than you might expect.
But despite being different,
Hungarian is really not as complicated
as people make it out to beat.
The noun cases aren't that hard to wrap
your head around.
If you think of them like post
positions,
vowel harmony isn't that hard to get
used to because there are a limited
number of variations and indefinite and
definite conjugations work very
logically.
It just takes some time to get used to
them.
And other aspects of Hungarian are quite
simple.
For example,
there's no grammatical gender at all and
adjectives and articles are not
inflected for case which makes dealing
with the cases much simpler.
The main point I'm getting at is that
after digging into Hungarian a little
bit,
just enough to make this language
profile,
I've come away with the impression that
it's not as complicated as I had been
led to believe.
So if you're interested in the Hungarian
people or the Hungarian culture or the
country of Hungary,
then don't be scared to start learning
the Hungarian language as well.
The question of the day to native
speakers of Hungarian,
what language or languages do you think
share the most similarities with
Hungarian and to learners of Hungarian?
What aspects of the language have you
found most challenging and what has been
more straight forward?
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
And once again,
thank you to all of my patrion
supporters,
especially the amazing ones right here
on the screen.
Who are my top tier patrons?
So many thanks to them as always and to
everyone else.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.